you know I keep wanting to look outside
to be sure it's not raining frogs
because the fact that I am now excited
about a guardians of the galaxy movie
has got to be a sign of the Apocalypse
so first teaser trailer for guardians of
the galaxy is out this was gonna be the
benchmark on whether or not they were
gonna get the tone of this thing right
do you know what nailed it
and it's constructed really well as a
teaser especially for this team of
Heroes that frankly nobody knows and
they know that so we get introduced to
all the characters focusing mostly on
star-lord and can I just point out that
I love the fact that as presented in
this teaser in this team of aliens which
includes a talking tree and a gun-toting
raccoon the goofy guy is the human you
know he thinks he's so much cooler than
he is and he's like he's just smartass
enough that he's funny but he's also a
little bloated on himself in that kind
of silly way oh man but in a fun way
Gamora who's you know she's all
Greenland she's badass and it's like the
green aliens that Kirk was always
seducing a Star Trek or like you know
what we're sick of being used we're
gonna kick some ass now that's the vibe
I get off her and I love it we don't
really get too much a sense of Drax the
destroyer aside from the fact that he
looks like he can kick a lot of ass but
you know when your name is Drax the
destroyer do we really need much more
from you than you're gonna kick a lot of
ass Rocket Raccoon
he just looks badass and a couple of
shots of action we get with him where
he's got the guns and just I love that
the tiniest goofiest character is not
being treated goofy that that ogre
chugga-chugga not only does it get a one
joke bit with the Walkman and in the
headphones but god Walkman I just dated
myself really badly but then they bring
it back during that and what's become
sort of the standard build in the audios
but and during that it comes back boo
got y'all go and it works really well it
and suddenly it's like almost bad as you
want to start pumping your fist oh good
Oh danke and john c reilly how great is
it to just hear him talk about these
characters I haven't forgotten he was
even in this thing how did that go over
my head but it just it's got this high
energy and it feels right feels right
what it should be I'm really excited
about this the only thing the only thing
that makes me a tiny bit nervous is the
use of hooked on a feeling as the title
came up it's just one tiny notch to
goofy like everything up to that point
I've been just goofy enough it was like
the perfect balance but then that is
like that's all that's a little too
jokey and James Gunn who's wrote and
directed this thing does that on
occasion where like he takes something
that's working but then just notches it
up a little more than he should then
again I'd rather have a film be mostly
on the money and take one step too far
rat rather than be dull and boring and
something I've seen a million times this
does not feel like something I've seen a
million times this looks like it's gonna
be a lot of fun and I'm definitely
excited about it so what was a movie
that you thought was gonna stink but
then suddenly a great trailer made you
go oh I couldn't see that let me know in
the comments until next time Council is
adjourned